so today's draft the players to make the
biggest leaps this year can be any
player any level any years of experience
doesn't have to be a young guy can be an
older guy last year on Tanana we saw the
leap he made all right Chris you have a
trivia question for me what do you got
okay well it's Kyle Emery related right
Kyle Murray played baseball as we all
know was drafted in the first round what
position Mike did Kyle Luhrmann
centerfield centerfield sorry really
yep it's left field at least that's what
I've been told I don't know that but
that's just the answer they gave me so
sorry there slugger oh wait you know
Wikipedia which is excellent because
anybody can put anything they want there
anytime they want so you always know
you're getting the best information I'm
gonna challenge that one centerfield the
fast guy always plays centerfield what
the hell's wrong with the Oklahoma
baseball coach you have somebody faster
who was playing centerfield
you need the big arm in that field
yeah there's not gonna be baseball this
year what else am I gonna not watch on
TV all right go ahead
baseball reference also had them at left
field so wicked centerfield I'd put them
in santa fe island by outfield positions
at the same time go ahead right fields
the the right fields the one you want
with the big arm just to clarify that
how those left field let me say
something right is where you get put in
little league where you're not when
you're not any good which is the
position you played in Little League
all right I mean I gotta take kind of
Murray with the first pick I do yeah I'm
sorry you know what's Italy consists of
I don't know Chi lumbering through what
22 twenty-something touchdown passes
last year how many interceptions I
should have probably looked that up but
I don't really care because I'm looking
for big-time leap this year out of him
where I just think one it's gonna be the
one of the most explosive offenses in
football Kliff Kingsbury proved to me
that he is capable of adapting the NFL
coming up with new ideas that
was really encouraging to me I think
he's really smart he's got guts which I
think will lead to them being a better
office but let alone hey Kenny on Drake
there he only got there halfway through
the year last year and of course DeAndre
Hopkins being there I think is I think
Tyler Murray yeah 20 touchdowns 12
interceptions last year I think could
very easily be 36 touchdowns and eight
or ten interceptions this year and in
the discussion for maybe MVP that the
team is good enough because you know the
team has to be good but certainly maybe
in the discussion for Offensive Player
of the Year I'm look I know we got to
move through this draft I've done a
quick google search and I'm getting a
lot of entries Kyler Murray centerfield
Kyler Murray played center field
adjusting the center field this is a
bunch of crap you better know what
position screw baseball-reference Kyler
Murray played center field alright
that's fine because look he's already
started a high spot it's gonna be hard
for him to make a leap give me drew
Locke drew like how do you not make drew
Locke the first pick he's a guy but drew
Locke has a lot more room yes to lead us
right right and we expect him to be
great and and he in a limited slice we
got a glimpse of what he can be and
Broncos fans who have suffered through
three straight losing seasons that's
about to change with Drew lock so good
for the Broncos to see the talent to
look past the fact that Missouri wasn't
very good his last year there that's not
on him the Broncos are are they still
gonna do with the Chiefs but they're in
good hands with Drew Locke that's my
pick no they definitely are I think it's
a great pick by you I think if if I was
to pick second and maybe you got that
trivia question right I probably would
have gone there too all right I don't
know you know what I'm gonna go off the
rails here a little bit alright and as a
shy yeah shocker I'm going with miles
Garrett all right and I say that because
we know how the year ended for him
he still had ten sacks I get that but I
just think between the circumstances of
what happened and then of course the
town with the player has and all of
those things I think you're gonna get an
extra motivated wanting to prove a lot
of people wrong type of play out of
Miles Garrett to where I'm saying
Defensive Player of the Year this year
I'm saying like eighteen nineteen sack
type of season that's what I'm expecting
I am I just think he's really gifted one
of the most talented players in the
league and I think you know yeah he's
gonna have a little bit of a chip on his
shoulder and also he was probably
humbled by some of what went on too and
I just expect him to be a guy that comes
back with you know dominance but but you
said you said the same stuff last year
defensive play the air you gonna are you
gonna predict these defensive player of
the year every year and then when he
doesn't get it he's gonna be your
candidate to make a big leap the next
year and finally be Defensive Player of
the Year you know somebody with a helmet
so that took a Stadium that took Azure
away and now that leaves them available
to have a huge leap and the next year to
have huge stats and be a big dominant
force and I think their team will be
better so go on I get your own pick I
got I got a miles in my own although he
spells it differently it's miles mi le s
miles Sanders the running back for the
Philadelphia Eagles he had 1300 yards
from scrimmage last year quietly I think
he's on the brink of being that kind of
special running back that the Eagles
need in order to get their offense where
it needs to go Chris yeah he's a good
football player no doubt and I do think
they need to ride the running back
position more so I could I could see a
big year him being more of a yeah Belk
out type runner more catches out of the
backfield he certainly has the skillset
to do all those type of things
juju Smith Schuster that's who I'm
looking for a leap in 2020 yeah he was
underwhelming last year right stats
weren't good I think this year he comes
back with big been healthy and has a
huge year I do you know they've made
some improvements on the offensive side
of the ball some of those guys are older
I think they'll be able to take some
pressure and heat off of them they got
an Eric Ebron and three
agency so I think with all those things
it's going to lead to a huge year for
juju Smith Schuster I think he makes a
giant leap from what he had in the 2019
season today I feel like the term leap
implies that it's the first time the
guys ever made a leap he's already had
his leap and then when they tried to
make it a number one receiver he
couldn't stretch the field deep he's not
a number one receiver they need someone
to emerge as the number one guy to take
the heat off of him because he's not
gonna beat double teams and he's not
gonna stretch the field he's very good
in his role when he can play his role
he's got to go back to being a number
two so a lot of ifs before you can get
it back to the sweet spot where juju
Smith Schuster needs to be sorry I
crapped on your pick last one for me and
I got a lot of different ones I can do I
want to go with Paris Campbell the Colts
receiver now that Philip Rivers is there
and look I'm taking a leap of faith that
Philip Rivers is gonna be better than
the guy that threw three interceptions
in a pair of prime time games last year
which I can't get out of my head but
Campbell a guy who didn't do much last
year who has that chance if the big wall
the wall they built the wall as you
would say and the running game goes the
passing game goes and Campbell should
get some favorable matchups and rivers
should be able to get in the ball Chris
yeah well listen I like that you know
you're right you know but no I didn't
think a leaf just had to be a guy who
did nothing and go you know into
superstardom whatever it may be but
Paris Campbell has a chance to be a
superstar I truly do believe that it's a
special skill set yeah he fought through
injuries last year so that's a good I
had him on my list honestly I just
thought the fact that he played so
little last year and didn't really get
on it I didn't want to use his name in
this I thought there were some better
options out there so that's my one
little one little crap on you okay the
drought all due respect I love you Chris
but the whole idea of the leap is it's
where you start and where you finish the
lower you slide you can start a leaders
gonna be that's ridiculous a leap is me
who else to jump rest so who else who
else did you have know Odell Beckham jr.
big horses yeah you also have any
lawyers TJ Hawkinson would be one the
tight end for the Detroit Lions who I
think is going to be emerged as one of
the
side ends in football this year I think
that's a guy I think Josh Jacobs is
another guy I would look at to be he
could have 2000 total yards at the end
of this year - those would be two other
guys that were around my list I had
another Raider Jonathan Abram he missed
a lot of time last year with an injury
he was looking like he was going to be
special their third of three first-round
picks in 2019 Montez sweat the
Washington pass rusher now that chase
young is there to complement him Quintin
Williams to the Jets defensive linemen I
can I can find plenty of things that say
center field as well so what is this
this is unfair I I throw the challenge
flag we got a Duke wrap or PST live
coming at you right after literally
literally
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports